2014년 3월 이집트는 한꺼번에 큰 결정들을 내리게 됩니다.
기준금리를 한 번에 6% 올렸고 오랫동안 버티던 환율도 풀었습니다.
달러당 30.85파운드 수준에 묶여있던 이집트 파운드는 49파운드 안팎까지 밀렸습니다.
파운드의 달러 가치를 기준으로 보면 약 38% 떨어진 겁니다.
같은 시기 이집트는 IMF 구제금융 규모도 기존 30억 달러에서 80억 달러로 늘렸습니다.
그런데 더 큰 사건은 따로 있었습니다.
이집트는 지중해 북서부의 핵심 해안 지역인 라스엘 헤크마 개발권을
아랍에미리트 쪽에 넘기고 총 350억 달러 규모의 계약을 맺었습니다.
이 돈이 전부 현금은 아니었습니다.
240억 달러가 신규 현금이었고 110억 달러는 기존에 아랍에미리트가 이집트에 넣어둔 예금을 투자로 전환하는 방식이었습니다.
이집트는 달러를 얻기 위해 국가의 핵심 해안 개발권까지 내놓아야 했던 겁니다.
이집트는 왜 이 지경까지 온 걸까요?
왜 화폐 가치를 낮추고 금리를 크게 올리고 IMF에 다시 손을 벌리고 해양 개발권까지 넘겨야 했을까요?
이 문제를 단순히 돈을 많이 써서 망했다 정도로 보면 핵심을 놓치게 됩니다.
이집트의 위기의 본질은 돈 부족이 아니라 달러 부족이었습니다.
이집트 안에서는 이집트 파운드를 쓸 수 있습니다.
하지만 해외에서 밀을 사고 연료를 사고 의약품과 기계를 들여오고 외채이자를 갚으려면
달러가 필요합니다.
문제는 이집트가 달러를 계속 써야 하는 나라였다는 점입니다.
그런데 달러를 벌어오는 힘은 충분히 커지지 않았고 반대로 달러를 갚아야 할 빚은 빠르게 늘었습니다.
이집트의 대외 부채는 2014년 약 418억 달러 수준이었습니다.
그런데 2023년에는 약 1682억 달러까지 늘었습니다.
10년도 안 되는 기간에 거의 4배가 된 겁니다.
물론 국가가 돈을 빌리는 것 자체가 무조건 문제는 아닙니다.
중요한 건 그 돈으로 무언가가 됩니다.
무엇을 했느냐입니다.
빌린 돈으로 공장을 짓고 항만을 키우고 수출기업을 늘리고 민간기업이 투자하기 좋은 환경을 만들었다면
나중에 달러를 벌어서 갚을 수 있습니다.
하지만 이집트의 많은 투자는 그런 방향과 거리가 있었습니다.
대표적인 사례가 신행정수도입니다.
이집트는 카이로에서 약 45km 떨어진 사막지역에 새로운 수도를 짓기 시작했습니다.
프로젝트 규모는 약 580억 달러 수준으로 알려져 있습니다.
물론 새로운 도구는
도시를 짓는 것 자체가 무조건 잘못은 아닙니다.
카이로는 인구가 많고 교통도 복잡하고 행정기능 분산도 필요했었습니다.
문제는 순서였죠.
이집트가 정말 급했던 것은 달러를 벌어오는 경제 기반이었습니다.
수출이 늘어야 했고 민간기업이 커져야 했고 외국기업이 들어와야 했고
관광과 물류 수입이 안정적으로 유지되어야 했습니다.
그런데 실제로는 거대한 건물, 신도시, 대형 인프라에만
많은 돈이 들어갔던 거죠.
이런 프로젝트는 국내 건설 경기를 띄우고 일자리를 만들 수는 있습니다.
하지만 외채를 갚을 만큼의 달러를 바로 만들어내기는 어렵습니다.
이집트의 문제는 건물을 지었다는 데 있지 않습니다.
달러로 빚을 냈는데 달러를 벌어오는 경제는 충분히 커지지 않았다는 데 있는 겁니다.
여기에 또 하나의 큰 문제가 있었습니다.
국가와 군의 경제 역할이 너무 커졌다는 점입니다.
2013년 LCC가 국가와 군의 경제 역할이 너무 커졌다는 점입니다.
군부 쿠데타 이후 권력을 잡았을 때
사우디아라비아와 아랍에미리트, 쿠웨이트 같은 걸프 국가들은
집권 직후 18개월 동안 약 230억 달러를 지원했습니다.
처음에는 급한 외환 위기를 막는 데 도움이 됐습니다.
하지만 이후 이집트 경제는 민간보다 국가와 군이 주도하는 방식으로 더 강하게 움직였습니다.
여기서 중요한 것은 군부 경제가 GDP의 정확히 몇 퍼센트냐가 아닙니다.
핵심은 민간 기업이 같은 조건에서 경쟁하기 어려운 구조가 만들어졌다는 점입니다.
국가나 군과 연결된 기업이 세금에서 유리하고 토지 접근에서 유리하고
정부 계약에서 유리하다면 민간 기업은 경쟁하기가 어렵습니다.
외국 기업도 마찬가지겠죠.
이건 다시 달러 문제로 이어집니다.
외국 기업이 들어오면 달러가 들어옵니다.
공장을 짓고 장비를 들어오고 수출을 하면 외화가 생기겠죠.
그런데 민간 기업이 위축되고 외국 자본이 망설이면 달러가 들어오는 통로도 약해집니다.
국가가 경제를 빠르게 밀어붙이면
겉으로는 성과가 보입니다.
하지만 민간 경제가 약해지면 장기적으로 외화를 벌어들이는 힘은 약해집니다.
그 상태에서 외부 충격이 왔습니다.
첫 번째 충격은 코로나였습니다.
이집트의 중요한 외화 수입원인 관광이 크게 흔들렸습니다.
두 번째 충격은 러시아의 우크라이나 침공이었습니다.
이집트는 세계에서 밀을 가장 많이 수입하는 나라 중 하나였고
전쟁 전 밀 수입의 상당 부분을 러시아와 우크라이나에 의존했습니다.
전쟁이 터지자 식량 수입 비용이 올라갔고 달러 부담도 커졌습니다.
여기에 금융시장 충격도 겹치게 됩니다.
2022년 우크라이나 전쟁 이후 이집트에서는 약 200억 달러의 포트폴리오 자금이 빠져나간 것으로 알려져 있습니다.
달러가 필요한 순간에 오히려 달러가 빠져나간 겁니다.
세 번째 충격은 홍해와 수해지 운하였습니다.
2023년 10월 이후 가자전쟁이 벌어졌고
예멘 호티반군이 홍해를 지나는 선박을 공격하기 시작했습니다.
그러자 많은 선박들이 홍해를 지나는 선박을 공격하기 시작했습니다.
이들이 수해지 운하를 피하고 아프리카 희망봉을 돌아가는 길을 선택했죠.
수해지 운하는 이집트가 가진 가장 중요한 외화 수입원 중 하나입니다.
2023년 수해지 운하 수입은 약 102억 5천만 달러였지만
2024년에는 약 39억 9천만 달러로 줄었습니다.
1년 만에 60% 넘게 감소한 겁니다.
관광이 흔들리고 식량 수입 부담이 커지고
외국 자금이 빠져나가고 수해지 운하 수입까지 줄었습니다.
이 모든 것이 같은 방향으로 줄었습니다.
달러가 부족해졌습니다.
그런데 이집트 정부는 오랫동안 공식 환율을 방어해왔다고 했죠.
2024년 초까지 공식 환율은 달러당 30.85파운드 수준에 묶여 있었습니다.
하지만 실제 시장에서는 그 가격의 달러를 구하기 어려웠고
병행 시장에서는 달러가 70파운드 안팎에서도 거래가 됐습니다.
쉽게 말하면 공식 가격과 실제 가격의 괴리가 커졌다는 의미겠죠.
이런 상황에서는 기업이 정상적으로 수입 계획을 세우기 어렵습니다.
이집트는 은행보다 암시장으로 가고 달러는 더 찾기 어려워집니다.
중앙은행은 환율을 지키기 위해 외환 보유액을 써야 합니다.
이 구조는 오래 버틸 수 없는 구조죠.
그래서 2024년 3월 이집트는 결국 환율을 조정했습니다.
공식 환율은 시장 가격에 가까워졌고 IMF 프로그램도 확대했습니다.
동시에 금리를 크게 올려서 물가와 자본 유출을 막으면서
단기적으로는 공식 환율과 병행 시장 환율의 차이가 줄었고
달러 부족도 완화되는 상황이었습니다.
하지만 환율을 조정했다고 해서 경제 구조가 바로 바뀐 것은 아닙니다.
2024년의 조치는 급한 위기를 멈추기 위한 조치였습니다.
이집트를 위기로 몰아넣은 문제들은 여전히 남아있는 겁니다.
가장 큰 문제는 이자 부담입니다.
2023년도와 2024년도 회계연도 첫 10개월 기준으로
이집트의 이자 지출은 GDP의 약 9%였습니다.
정부 총 지출의 51%가 이자였고
정부 총 수입의 84%에 해당하는
정부 총 수입의 84%에 해당하는 구조였습니다.
정부가 돈을 벌어도 대부분이 과거 빚의 이자를 갚는 데 들어간다는 뜻입니다.
이런 구조에서는 교육, 의료, 산업, 복지에 돈을 쓰기 어렵습니다.
또 하나의 과제는 민간 부분의 회복입니다.
이집트가 다시 안정되려면 외부에서 돈을 받는 것만으로는 부족합니다.
국가와 군이 차지하고 있던 경제 공간 일부를 민간 기업이 들어오면서
투자도 하고 외국 기업이 들어오고 수출 기업이 늘어나야 합니다.
하지만 이 부분의 개혁은 빠르게 진행되고 있지 않습니다.
현재 이집트 경제는 2024년 3월처럼 급한 외환 위기에서는 벗어났습니다.
성장률과 물가도 일부 안정됐습니다.
하지만 회복됐다는 말과 안전해졌다는 말은 다릅니다.
이집트는 여전히 외부 충격에 취하갑니다.
중동 정세가 흔들리면서 관광 수입이 줄고 홍향로가 불안해지면서 수혜주의나 수입도 흔들리고 있습니다.
이런 중동 갈등이 장기화되면서 식량이나 에너지 가격이 오르면 수입 비용이 늘고
외국인 자금이 빠져나가면 환율과 물가가 다시 압박을 받을 수 있습니다.
이집트 이야기를 보면서 우리도 생각해볼만한 것들이 있습니다.
국가는 큰 건물들을 세울 수 있습니다.
새 도시를 만들 수 있고 다리를 놓고 철도를 깔고 세계에서 가장 높은 빌딩을 올릴 수도 있습니다.
겉으로 보기에는 분명 성장처럼 보입니다.
하지만 정말 중요한 질문은 따로 있겠죠.
그 성장이 스스로 돈을 벌어오는 성장인가 아니면 빚을 내서 미래의 시간을 앞당겨 쓴 것인가.
이집트가 보여준 문제는 단순히 한 나라의 실패가 아닙니다.
오늘날 많은 나라들이 이집트의 성장을 통해 성장하는 것입니다.
많은 나라들이 비슷한 유혹을 받습니다.
눈에 보이는 개발, 숫자로 보이는 성장률, 화려한 국가 프로젝트.
그런데 그 뒤에서 민간 경제가 약해지고 생산성이 낮아지고 외부 충격의 버티림이 줄어든다면
그 성장은 생각보다 쉽게 흔들릴 수 있습니다.
경제는 결국 건물의 높이로 증명되지 않습니다.
위기가 왔을 때 버틸 수 있는 기업이 있는지, 스스로 외화를 벌어올 산업이 있는지,
국민의 삶을 지탱할 생산성이 있는지로
증명됩니다.
이집트는 급한 위기를 넘겼습니다.
하지만 그 위기가 끝났는지는 아직 알 수 없습니다.
어쩌면 이집트가 우리에게 던지는 질문은 하나일지도 모릅니다.
우리가 성장이라고 부르는 것들 중에서 진짜 미래를 만드는 투자는 얼마나 될까?
그리고 미래의 부담을 오늘의 성과처럼 보이게 만드는 투자는 얼마나 될까?
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.